thank you
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man
and things are going great oh yeah you
were supposed to be here all right
whatever whatever wow whatever so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian I am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
[Music]
he's lying lying to you and I think you
know it
[Music]
wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's it I gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 come on go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter
you have a baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both
her man always always what about Uncle
Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of us
wouldn't be here
[Music]
I can't run forever dude
isn't what we talked about you know
there's no idea what are you doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own
stations stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked at my uncle and ah let
me guess he died